[Music]
mark Aronson is the author of witch-hunt
mysteries of the Salem witch trials next
he reconsiders the case with a group of
middle schoolers or the same age as the
accusers were in 1692 this event is
about 55 minutes good morning everybody
and welcome to Barnes & Noble it's nice
to see a lot of familiar faces I see
you've been here before and I've been
able to enjoy these wonderful
presentations that we can bring to you
well today we're very excited because
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a trip back in time to Salem
Massachusetts and to help us do that we
have acclaimed historian and author Marc
Aronson with us and he's going to tell
us some fascinating stories of the Salem
witch trials so I hope that you can help
me in welcoming the man behind this
incredible new book witch hunt
mr. Marc
thank you I am a historian now just
remind me of all of you which school do
you go to well I have a doctorate in
history I spent a lot of time studying
it but I decided to write my books for
you
I wanted to write books for people who I
think have really alive minds which is
what I think people your age do and
that's because I think history is the
most alive topic of all people often
think of history as sort of dead and
dull memorizing facts it's just the
opposite because the historian does two
things and those are the two things
we'll do today on the one hand the
historian is a detective I was watching
Law & Order the other night that's what
a historian does you go out you collect
facts you collect evidence and you make
up a theory what does it add up to what
does it tell us so on the one hand
you're an investigator but the other
thing history does history is a mirror
when you look in the past you see
yourself a historian is like a novelist
because the more you look into the past
the more you see into the deepest parts
of your own heart and that's what we're
going to do today because there's no
subject which is both more of an
interesting investigation and more of a
mirror of who we are as people than the
subject of the Salem witch trials now
let me just ask you very briefly how
many of you know what happened in Salem
in 1692
I'd seem like someone excuse accuse
somebody of being a witch because that
um some people at their house and they
started acting all weird and then it's
elect to a bunch of other accusations
and they all started like accusing each
other and people died we'll get into all
of those details did anybody know how
many people were executed in Salem by
the courts in 1692 as witches let's take
a guess how many people think it was
five and under Tannen under 15 and under
20 and under it was 19 people
19 people were executed one person was
crushed by stones because the rules at
the time were that if he refused to
testify they keep putting stones on your
chest until you spoke or died he died
and at least five people died in prison
including a number of infants okay we're
gonna try to figure out why that
happened and the center of why it
happened as we just heard is that a
group of people testified in court that
these 19 individuals and many others
were witches
the people who testified primarily were
you they were people your age there were
people your age who committed legal
murder that is to say they got the
courts to kill people for them so the
question I want you to think about today
as we talk and if you read my book
afterwards is what would make you do it
what would make you use the courts to
kill people to kill people you perhaps
had never met so we're gonna do that by
looking at history but in order to begin
the process of looking back I think we
need to look inside I remember when I
was in eighth grade there were rumors
there were rumors because there was a
set of bomb scares in my school there
were some thefts in the school there
were rumors about romances family
problems
my son is three and a half so I don't
know what the current rumors are in
eighth grade although I would suspect
that at least shortly after Columbine or
shortly after 9/11 there were people who
might have wondered looking at somebody
in the hallway is he someone I need to
worry about is he someone dangerous so I
want you to think about this what if you
had a friend who pointed someone out to
you someone sort of weird and on the
edges someone sort of unpopular and said
you know I know he's plotting something
you know I know he wants to kill us
and what if that person said I'm gonna
go talk I'm gonna go talk to the
teachers and what if you kind of half
thought she was right what if you had
noticed him sketching something it
looked kind of like a gun what if you
knew he had a website and had weird
things on it but what if you also
weren't sure she was right and what if
you also felt that if she went and
talked and she was wrong she was going
to get in trouble and she was going to
be really mad at you and she might even
imply that you were in on the plot and
so you would have a choice if you go
along with her you might be getting
someone innocent in trouble if you don't
go along with her you might be letting a
killer loose and you might be getting
yourself in trouble so keep that in mind
keep that scenario in your mind and
we'll start to go back and look back in
the past and I'll give you some evidence
and I want you to tell me what you think
of that evidence because we're going to
evaluate things how many of you have
read anything at all about Salem a
fiction or nonfiction what did you read
no but I'm the name of what you read
okay looks like a break with charity or
sure great now that that's a person
after my own heart
okay well the most standard way when you
guys read about Salem the most standard
way the beginning of the outbreak in
Salem is described is somewhat similar
to what we just heard there was a
minister in Salem and he had a slave a
slave from Barbados in most accounts
that you will read this is a black woman
from Barbados who brought with her some
kind of island knowledge some kind of
semi voodoo who was in some way more
alive more more vital than the girls in
New England and the girls in New England
who were very kind of frosty and cold
and repressed were drawn to this black
woman and eager to learn from her but
suddenly panicked they panicked that's
something that they were learning that
this woman was sort of telling them
telling their fortunes telling their
future and then these girls including
children of ministers suddenly got
fearful of something that they'd heard
from her and started to accuse people of
being witches well I'm gonna read to you
two descriptions from the time and these
are on pages 60 and 61 to different
people who saw these girls who are
starting to have really weird symptoms
and I want you to listen to these two
descriptions and tell me which one you
believe here's the first one
the girl seemed to be pinched and bitten
by invisible agents their arms necks and
backs turned this way in that and
returned again sometimes they were taken
dumb their mouths stopped their throats
choked their limbs racked and tormented
that's one description of what kids your
age were doing after they got perhaps
spooked here's a different description
the girls quote began to act after a
strange and unusual manner as by getting
into holes and creep
chairs and stools and to use sundry odd
postures and antic gestures uttering
foolish ridiculous speeches which
neither they themselves nor any others
could make sense of in other words were
the girls in the throes of some kind of
torment that they didn't understand were
they feeling possessed or were they just
acting were they just having a good time
playing so all right let's vote all of
you who think that the girls actually
felt that they were under some kind of
attack that they couldn't understand
that their bodies were not in their own
control raise your hand
Wow a solitary vote how many who think
the girls were acting we're making it up
Wow a group of skeptics well there's
gonna be evidence for you in evidence
against you I how many of you have
friends relatives whatever who are
medical doctors okay I described this
set of symptoms to my doctor one time
when I went in for a checkup and without
missing a beat he said hysteria those
symptoms the choking the going rigid and
the feeling the bent the pinches are
symptoms of hysteria in other words
someone who's had a terrifying
experience of profound fright would show
those symptoms beyond her control
so this those of you who might be are
one believer we have to ask what could
have frightened them so much so we're
starting out we've got a lot of skeptics
here that'll be interesting well let's
go back to the story I told you the name
of that slave was Tituba Tituba was the
name of the the slave of the minister
this is a plantation record from
Barbados it's on pages 64 and 65 it
shows a record of slaves held in a
plantation one of the the names on here
is Tituba very likely this is the record
of the the where Tituba came from on
this record is also a man named John in
the Salem witch trial
tituba's husband is also named he was
one of the accusers her husband's name
was John Indian it was very common at
the time to use as a part of persons
name a description of the person there
are two black people who were involved
in the Salem witch trials one of whom
was named Mary [ __ ] the other was named
candy and she was described as black
Tituba was described as tawny tan not
black in other words it is very likely
the titular was not black she was like
her husband an Indian now why does this
matter it matters for two reasons again
I was telling you about a detective
story it means that most books you were
going to read about Salem are wrong they
start out with misinformation the second
is that New Englanders at this time were
terrified of Indians we'll get to that
in a moment
so the direct link between kitsch above
being an Indian and what might have
caused these girls to be so frightened
is explained but there's a second thing
remember I was telling you the story
about maybe Tituba had this island
knowledge that these girls who were sort
of repressed were yearning for Tituba
States over and over again in the trial
records and by the way if any of you
want to read the actual records from the
Salem witch trials they're on the
Internet I give you the address in my
book you can read all the entire account
of the trials Tituba
insists that she did not know any ritual
magic and that if in any magic that she
was forced to perform with talk to her
by white people including her mistress
in in Barbados well I'd like to show you
something one of the main implements
used in ritual magic at the time was
what was called a poppet it's like a
puppet but it's more like what we would
now call a voodoo doll it was not done
for entertainment the idea is that you
would create a ritual image and that a
witch could use this to transmit evil if
you look on page 34 in my book you'll
see two photos of a poppet that was
found in a home on Cacho Long Island
inside the walls it was hidden there the
English people of New England used folk
magic all the time
this was not something that had to be
imported to them from the islands so if
we go back to the story that again you
will find in almost every book you read
about Salem black woman from the islands
brings magic to up tight New England
completely wrong Indian woman comes to
New England that is already filled with
its own folk magic the reason why I'm
telling you this is one to sharpen your
sense of history as a detective story
you've got to pay attention for over a
hundred years history's got this wrong
but second of all to show you that much
is going in the past means using what
you think is so it also means constantly
questioning what you think is so so now
that we've started out with the rumor
story I told you and our caution I'm
going to give you some informations and
I would like to hear your reactions to
them the way the Salem witch trials
worked is these starting with these
three girls who were again your age they
would accuse someone of being a witch
imagine any one of you standing up here
you would come in for a pre trial here
and you would stand here and everyone
out there would say wouldn't testify the
way you see on TV oh yesterday I saw you
do this they would claim that standing
right there in the court the invisible
ghost of the witch was attacking them
that the attack was happening right
there as they were standing let me
describe read to you one moment and
those of you who are skeptics pay
attention because there is a crucial
piece of evidence for you in this moment
is a woman named Martha Corey was
accused of being a witch she was a very
good woman church-going woman highly
regarded everyone in town liked her but
I'm every time Martha bit her lip some
of the afflicted women and girls would
howl that they were being bitten and
would insist on being exact
to show the telltale marks they would
actually say CC I'm being bitten here's
the bite marks they even claimed that
they could show her exact teeth pattern
in the bites on on their arms if Martha
rubbed her hands together as any nervous
person might do while being questioned
more protests would come from the
audience more demands to reveal the
accusers battered limbs if Martha so
much is leaned forward to rest on her
seat screams came from the crowd It was
as if good Martha Corey sitting in the
meeting house were a shell of a person
while her evil ghost floated above the
crowd pulling at her puppet victims on
invisible strings feeding off one
another the accusers were like a pack of
wild animals one darting ahead with some
aggressive behavior and the others
rushing in to follow her lead mrs. Pope
this was an adult woman screamed that
her very bowels were being torn out by
the witch and she began to throw things
at Martha then others started hurling
accusations at Martha as if they were
the judges directing the testimony
why wasn't Martha out with the other
witch spirits who were gathering in
front of the meeting house didn't she
hear the drum beating calling her wasn't
the yellow bird drinking its evil juice
from between her fingers that very
moment witches were thought to have
familiars animals that could do their
bidding and they claimed that right
there in the court this yellow bird was
drinking this juice from between her
fingers the judges look quickly to see
if there were any evidence of suckling
Mark's on Martha's hands but the
accusing girls were too quick Martha had
already spirited away they claimed a pin
perhaps to draw blood for the bird and
the pin was found sticking up right out
of Martha's head and now I'm going to
show you something this is on page 110
this is a 19th century photo of a bottle
found in it no longer exists but in this
bottle which was found in Massachusetts
are pins which scholars say were 17th
century pens so these were pins that
were recovered from the Salem witch
trials now I ask you skeptics and
believers what was going on in court
and what crucial piece of evidence have
I given to the skeptics
any future prosecutors any future
defense lawyers alright I'll give you
the answer
well yes speak yes
all right folks think about it if there
are pins in court how did they get there
yes okay if someone snuck them in what
does that suggest yes sir
you've set a keyword keyword planning
pins equals planning if you've got
something in court that you need to have
there to draw evidence
someone must have plotted to do it any
other thoughts is there any alternative
possible explanation for the pins we had
one believer
I'll give you an alternative possible
explanation if if people just happen to
have a pin on them and you suddenly
point say oh that's the pin that's the
pin so the question is how many people
may have just had pins on them that
people in court suddenly claimed were
evidence but for those who are skeptics
the pins are the very best evidence but
now skeptics you've had an easy ride so
far now you come to the question of why
and I'm back to you it's you it's people
your age why are you gathering at the
end of your day to plot that tomorrow
you're going to bring pins into court to
cause Martha Corey one of the most best
like women in town to die so yes sir
maybe you're jealous of her I'll say
jealous is a possibility Ellis of her in
which way do you man she's well-liked
and if some of the people who are doing
this aren't as well-liked so we have a
kind of an emotional imbalance that
that's one possibility two people who
spoke you haven't spoken maybe they were
just like they wanted to do something
like for fun or entertainment or
something and they thought it was funny
for some reason there is one person in
the trial record when pressed to ask why
they did it said we did it for sport we
must have some sport that's what you've
said but now you ask yourself something
folks let's say it started out that way
let's say you had fun like the skeptic
said at the beginning acting in weird
ways and getting attention what happens
when the result of your doing that is
people starting to die at what point
does the transition happen from fun to
murder yes you were had your hand up
question about the pins yes like why
would they have pins on them to be well
to hold together some part of their
clothing when it was in her head well no
it was in her hair like it you could say
like a hairball
it wasn't like sticking in like you know
well we don't know we just have that
description the person in red because
they were accused of being witches
themselves that certainly did start to
happen and we'll talk about that in the
moment yes sir maybe like the lady had
something that they wanted that like was
hard to get from her if she liked what
didn't like mmm have time to guard it
there are two ways in which that may be
true there was a very deep division in
Salem at this time some of the families
in Salem especially the farmers were not
doing well economically they were
starting to loot decline
some families in Salem especially the
merchants involved in trade overseas
we're starting to do well most of the
accusers came from the declining the
families that were getting poorer most
of the accused came from the families
that were doing better but and this is
the question again it comes back to you
that was the parents that was the
fathers who were declining economically
the accusers were mainly you so you have
to ask yourself I'm sure you all hear
your parents at time saying things about
people they don't they may not like one
political party or another they may not
like some neighbors or another but at
what point what would you have to hear
at home that would result in your
actually going to court and accusing
someone in a way that they will die so
there's certainly war tensions in the
town but you have to ask yourselves as
people your age what would make you be
the puppet the spokesmen the mouthpiece
for those tensions how high would they
have to be there is also a theory that
the sheriff that a when if you were
convicted of being a witch
the sheriff would by the way which could
be male or female it didn't imply female
if you were accused of being a witch and
convicted the sheriff would sweep into
your house and take all your possessions
and that was legal and there is a theory
that the sheriff was working with the
accusers so that basically the accusers
would set someone up the sheriff would
take the goods the problem with that
theory is that the accusations were so
random they didn't concentrate in a
place where the sheriff was really
building up a huge pile of income did
you have your hand up okay
well we've got some on the skeptic side
you're beginning to bring up some of the
theories that could explain it but again
I want let me ask you that question
let's say you heard your parents be
really annoyed at somebody some other
group of people in in town would you go
to court to be the voice of that and
what what do you think would make you do
it to take the risk to go to court to
accuse a neighbor person who might live
in the house next to you
of something that would result in their
being killed yes money that would be so
although it's been very hard to trace
out any direct link and yes maybe if
their parents were threatening them in
some way that is a possibility there's
no evidence of it everyone knew she bit
her lip at the same time well this is
just look all we have is the transcripts
we have the transcript of the pre-trial
hearings maybe if you were hearing like
things in town and then you heard your
parents talking bad about them too you'd
get like scared and you felt like that
like you couldn't get in trouble if you
were just saying it because you're a kid
the exemption for childhood didn't
really exist however the idea that what
your parents were saying is what people
were saying in town one thing feeding on
the other I think that is possible that
is certainly possible yes maybe they
wanted to get back at them or something
like when people sort of died maybe they
saw like oh they won't be my way ever
again well let me ask you guys something
something you probably do it all about
let's talk about how cliques function it
seems to me a clique in group needs two
things and correct me if I'm wrong I
think a clique needs two things it needs
a leader and it needs a way to patrol
its borders in other words it needs to
decide who's in and who's out and it
needs a center does that make sense or
if I left something out what else is
central to making a clique work function
what holds it together
well you've spoken no idea like that
you're spoken but that's yes sir
something in common with all the people
that's interested that's a kind of a
nice way to put it any other ideas
you guys got to know this what makes
cliques work what what holds them
together you're saying something over
there
what makes cliques work they work there
exist what what's you
yes this gentleman has an idea a belief
okay again this is putting it Potsie I
think my guess is the cliques work more
emotionally that it's not just about
saying hey we all like stamp collecting
I think it's about we're together and
they're not it's about us and them and
so let's talk about how the attackers at
Salem patrolled their borders and we
know that because one woman a woman
named Mary Warren initially said they're
all lying it's all lies what do you
think immediately happened yes sir a
gentleman in back uh the people in town
might have accused her of being a witch
yes she was trying to get off the
subject they the minute she accused the
other accusers of lying she was accused
of being a witch back to the story I
told you in the beginning about rumors
in school
okay she's accused of being a witch how
could she save her life what option does
she have
how can she she's now accused of being a
witch what can she do this gentleman
back there she could run away some
people did actually run away although
the people who ran away tended to be
really rich and and they could get away
Mary Warren was a servant she didn't
have that same freedom of action yes sir
I don't think you've spoken
you're tied again that's like running
away she in the back some stuff on
detailing which tiles on the Internet
and it said that some people if they
agreed and confessed that they were like
witches they wouldn't like be convicted
like people that is completely correct
in other words once you if you said
they're lying you were accused of being
a witch you stood in threat of your life
if you said they're there right there
are witches I corroborate their story
you were safe
now you were put in jail but people
ignored you people weren't interested in
you you had to it you had to say they
were right and you had to accuse other
people of being witches you could accuse
people who are already accused so if you
felt you were lying you wouldn't
necessarily feel so bad because you
could just simply name people who had
already been named or even already
executed nonetheless you had to agree
that the story was true
so back yes if you are convicted of
being a witch prior you ask a very good
question prior to the Salem witch trials
there were many other trials for
witchcraft in New England if you were
convicted of being a witch by law you
were hanged however in most of the
trials prior to Salem even people
convicted were not executed in Salem if
you were convicted you were hanged if
you confessed you were put in jail and
basically ignored no one quite knows
what would have happened to them later
they were just sort of taken off stage
so here you have a kind of momentum
let's say one of you say said maybe it
started out as fun a sport they're kind
of acting they're enjoying getting
attention they're enjoying everybody all
being in a hubbub now you're starting to
have court cases now you're starting to
have people convicted now you're
starting to have people hanged and now
you're starting to have the pressure
that if you you break ranks you're going
to be
brought in court your only safety is to
say it's true there are witches and I
know them the what's the obvious effect
it's growing it's getting bigger
there are more and more people being
accused because everyone's getting on
board everyone's joining the program now
I said a clique needs a leader there is
a woman there are there is a candidate
for being a woman who may have been at
the heart of all of it
want to guess how old she was we got a
vote for 13 any other votes she was 12
she was 12 and in 1706 she came before
her church and she she handed the
minister a piece of paper she stood up
before the whole church and the minister
read saying she said that she did it she
said I was a chief instrument of
accusing people who who died and she
said I desire to lie in the dust and to
be humbled for it that I was a cause
with others of so sad a calamity so she
said she was a cause why did she do it I
did it not out of any anger malice or
ill will but what what I did was
ignorant ly being deluded by Satan in
other words she confessed without
confessing she said absolutely nothing
so her name is Ann Putnam I do describe
in this book
why and Putnam might have been the
center of the attacking group the center
of the accusers the center of the
killers yes they're witches know that
who were witches like the people
themselves like do they know or not
well there is remember I said back to
how my doctor said that that the
symptoms I described were the classical
symptoms of hysteria
there is one historian who has argued
that there actually were witches in
Salem not people who had supernatural
powers but people who practiced a kind
of ritual magic that the girls could
have been so terrified by that they were
hysterical most people do not believe
that is true they do believe that people
used puppets that there was some kind of
folk magic but they don't believe it was
an actual belief in what would now be
called Wicca or anything like that that
is most people do not believe that was
true yes sir like the it started out as
a joke and then it became something more
serious and the girls didn't know what
to do that is one theory I'm about to
give you another theory because we did
have one believer and remember I said
that people in New England were more
scared of Indians or very scared of
Indians
why were they why was this so well at
that time the state of Maine or the
colony of Maine did not exist it was
part of Massachusetts in Maine there had
recently been a series of very violent
Indian Wars wars with the Wabanaki
people during these attacks which were
extremely gruesome some of the the
people who later came to Salem and
testified saw their families killed
before their eyes one in particular
Marcie Lewis was three most of her
family was killed she and her parents
barely escaped Marcie Lewis became an
putnams servant it is possible that
Marcie Lewis was having visions visions
where what had in life been real
attackers real people drawing blood real
people destroying her family became in
her vision witches and it is possible
that Ann Putnam who we think of as the
leader of the attacking group was
herself the puppet of mercy Lewis
scholars who are working on this
now are paying more and more attention
to Mercy Lewis but now I'm going to
remember I said about how history is a
mirror we're gonna come really close to
the present there's another way in which
the Indian attacks may have affected
Salem because there's a question we
haven't answered here in New England at
this time someone asked would you get an
exemption by being a kid well in New
England at this time adults were always
believed more than children men were
always believed more than women
ministers were always believed more than
laypeople in the Salem witch trials 11
year old girls convicted a male minister
and he was executed the question we have
to ask is why did the rules change why
did the judges believe when in every
prior case they would have accepted the
word of the minister over the word of
certainly an 11 year old girl a 12 year
old girl can anyone guess or think about
why that might have been here yes the
judges were afraid that if they didn't
convict them they would be accused as
well say there was that fear although
the question is why were they if what
were they afraid of being accused of and
look I mean yes maybe once you're
convicted of being a witch or whatever
um then you have that like burden on you
and people start to not believe you
anymore that that could be true but what
you have to ask why did the judges
believe the kids from the beginning from
the very beginning and here we get I
mean first of all I think think in your
school in general I would assume
teachers are believed more than students
but I am certain that if there are
certain kinds of accusations that a
student brings up the administration
would listen if you claim that a teacher
was doing something really inappropriate
or illegal and that you knew about it
the administration would probably listen
yes sir
maybe they believe the kids over the
adults because if there was a risk that
the adults were actually witches and
they were harmful they were they
wouldn't be willing to take the risk and
leave them alone that is that's if they
actually believe that the adults were
witches here's the other theory and it
gets us right down to the present it now
turns out that many of the judges had
some responsibility in the Indian Wars
that there were rumors that they had
sold guns to the Indians that they had
made deals with the Indians that they
had been particularly weak or
ineffectual in dealing with the Indians
so how convenient for the judges to say
gee it's not that we blew it and many
people died it's that there's a demonic
attack so it may be that the judges
accepted the argument about witches
because it deflected attention from
their own failings and again I think of
the president we're having all these
debates about the Iraq war about what we
did right or did wrong and what should
we have invaded or did we have enough
evidence what if something suddenly came
up that completely distracted our
attention and we didn't have to pay
attention to those questions a lot of
people would be very happy that is one
theory that of what happened at Salem
and I want to bring that question of the
parallel between then and now up in a
different way prior to the Salem witch
trials there was one thing that people
in New England particularly detested in
about the Spanish Inquisition and that
was that when the Spanish Inquisition
tried to investigate people of being
witches or of being of not having the
proper faith they used torture the
people in New England were so proud of
the fact that they did not use torture
in Salem people were tortured they were
tortured psychologically and physically
there were boys who were hung upside
down in a kind of horseshoe until the
blood ran out of their noses okay why
did the rules change on torture at Salem
yes
because they believe that the witches
could reverse the physical effects no
good it's a good idea but it's not
correct all right you guys know what
happened
between September 10th and September
11th 2001 in American law about torture
since September 11 2001 when we have
captured suspected al-qaeda terrorists
and I'm not saying this out of any
extremity it's been written about in the
New York Times in the Wall Street
Journal
we'd deprive them of sleep we shine
lights in their face and we turn them
over to countries where torture is legal
we do this because it is our belief that
it is more important that we protect
ourselves than that we protect the
rights of someone who's committed to the
destruction of the United States we have
changed our view of torture within our
own recent lifetime that is exactly what
happened at Salem they were so
frightened they were so frightened that
torture became acceptable and that's
what happened to us yes did you raise
your hand no there's a woman in red
okay all right well now let me ask you
this question folks we've got skeptics
here we've described what was going on
we've described the power of the click
what stopped it what could have stopped
the trials what could have made why
didn't this why don't we still have
witch trials yes
um they finally figured out that there
aren't actually any witches that it was
all just a belief that was spread around
no so many people like dying like it's
in like I don't like doesn't really
matter after which there's something not
like they're gonna hurt anyone probably
no think back to yourself remember I
told you this rumor story remember I
told you the question of will you
corroborate the other person's story or
not
ask yourself here you're in the
situation now people are dying now
nineteen people have yes sir maybe some
of the rumors stop spreading why would
they stop spreading and not sure okay
here's this gentleman everybody started
agreeing with other people and also like
not saying that anybody's lying you're
onto something
maybe there's no one left to keys oh
there were plenty of people left to
accuse yes maybe the girls were getting
scared so they stopped spreading rumors
and they thought the girls were becoming
evermore powerful yes they were just
bored with the rumors think back to
yourselves folks think back to the
choice that you have when your friend is
asking you to go and back up her story
yes they'd like two people to change the
story so they didn't have to get
convicted some you've got it some of the
people who admitted being witches
recanted they said I lied they said they
admitted having lied even though they
knew it could cost them their lives they
said I would rather tell the truth
then let this go on two women did that
and then I will show you one of the most
powerful powerful pieces that comes out
of Salem one woman named Mary easty
wrote this petition this petition which
is on page 174 in my book Mary easty
said I know I will die I know you will
convict me but let no more innocent
blood be shed she gave up her life to
get people to stop to stop the carnival
of destruction and when Mary easty took
that personal choice that moral choice
as had Sarah Churchill to say there are
no witches I will not protect myself I
must stop this it did stop the most
important minister in all of New England
increased math Mather who believed
deeply in witches said better that nine
real witches
free then that one innocent person died
and so I take you back to where we are
now and what I was said about torture we
no longer believe that we would
certainly all believe better that nine
terrorists be captured then that one
innocent person you know be be jailed we
have changed our views I'm not saying
that we're wrong to change our views we
are in a state of war but nonetheless
when I said Salem is a mirror it brings
us back to our moral choices witches
were as real to people in Salem as
al-qaeda is to us if any of you on
September 10th 2001 said to me that
there was a terrorist organization out
there training people with the plan of
flying planes into the World Trade
Center I'd say you're watching too many
war movies you've made it up
what Salem reminds us of is moral choice
in a time of fear moral choice in a time
of fear in 1692 led to 25 people dying
19 people being executed on your word
the word of people your age the choice
we face today I mean when we read about
our own civil rights and our own
response to terror is what choice are we
making and that's why I say history is
the most alive of topics
it's about sorting this evidence and
it's about making sense of who we are as
people that's why I write these books
thanks for listening to me and later
[Applause]
yeah any questions yes sir
ma'am yeah all right what why D powdi
you decide to write nonfiction instead
of like fiction or whatever cuz I love
research I love looking into the past
and also because nonfiction is true it's
what it's it's I'm doing my best to
figure out what is actually true yes sir
is it based on a true story this is all
true none of it is a story it's all true
yes what got you interested in the topic
of the Salem witch trials like why did
you decide to write about them instead
of any other time well I as I said I
have a doctorate in American history I
was always fascinated by the colonial
period it was a period in which religion
was really important in people's
thinking my grandfather was a rabbi came
out of a world that was very devout and
so I'm sort of interested in the time
where people when religion means a lot
to people and what happens to them in
those periods
that's why yes why were they only jailed
in people who are just innocent were
killed that's one of the mysteries of
sale basically what happened is they
were jailed because they were sort of no
one cared about them anymore whereas if
you fought if you said I'm not a witch
the court would say yes you are yes you
are yes you are you'll die it is
possible if the trials hadn't stopped
that all those people who were in jail
would later have been hanged but for the
moment they were sort of warehouse they
were sort of just taken off stage Tituba
for example admitted to being a witch
put in jail and disappeared from history
no one knows what became of her yeah
um how much does each book cost you'll
have to ask Deborah yes sir you realize
you want to write books oh that's a good
question I also have another career as
an editor I edit books for you guys and
as I was working on other people's books
I sort of thought hey I can do this too
so I'd say I don't know about eight
years ago something like that well there
are questions back there yeah do you
have other books that you wrote Barisan
with this yeah well I wrote a book on
Sir Walter Raleigh and the quest for El
Dorado that won a prize I wrote a book
called Art Attack which is all about
really crazy and wild art I have a book
coming out this spring which is about
the period in American history where we
were in effect a fundamentalist
religious utopian community and then I
have a book coming out about the
revolution next year and my argument is
that the history of India is as
important to the history the American
Revolution as the history of America so
that'll be out next year yes oh I don't
know about six months more or less I
played a lot I loved playing loud music
when I write so it's very inspiring so I
listen to a lot of loud music which
drives my wife crazy and I wrote yes do
you believe in which is not in the sense
that I think that there are people who
have any particular are called power I
think there are people who who who try
to influence the world oh I think that
almost everybody here believes in
magical thank me and I'll give my last
night I was watching the Nets game I
live in New Jersey I'm a nets fan Nets
had won 14 straight I was hoping they'd
win their 15th I was afraid they would
lose I was wondering what in what I was
doing in watching the game would help
them win or lose that is magical
thinking that's the idea that somehow
what I do is going to have
effect on Jason Kidd of course it won't
but I think we all think that way when
you really want something you think what
can I do what ritual can I perform can I
be nice to someone I've been mean to can
I do my homework and I'll get what I
want that's magical thinking and we all
do it so I think we all have magical
thinking
I don't believe witches have any
particular powers yes look did you find
most interesting - like whoa - whatever
I'm working on is the most interesting
it's the it's the research process I
mean there's there's something really
weird and spooky about reading about
Salem there's no doubt about it
and so that that's kind of cool yeah so
the people who admitted they were witch
like they never like got hanged or
anything that's correct
they lived they lived and many yes they
did yes
what was your first book heart attack in
the future do you want your son to
become an author oh my wife and my
wife's also an author and and we really
hope he'll go into Wall Street and make
millions
well books have you edited oh I edit an
author named Paul Fleischman who's won
the Newbery and so I add a lot of his
books and other books like that yes your
first book when did I start it think in
97 or 98 something like that yes I got
the Seibert award which is the
equivalent of the Newberry for
nonfiction what kind of books did you
wife right she writes primarily fiction
for adults but she also writes about
immigrant teenagers for teenagers she
writes about the experiences of
teenagers who who have immigrated to
America someone back there
what kind of lab music do you listen to
yeah.well mclecklin my age I listen to
two things Bob Dylan and opera so I like
things I like music that overwhelms me
that makes me feel like that the crest
of emotion in the music is like a river
is like a current and it fills me and
then I want to put that current into
what I'm saying my wife wants silence
yes sir about writing fiction books I've
thought about it I've thought about it
and I may but I just love history I love
trying to figure out what happened what
happened how did it happen yeah do you
have a favorite author or a favorite
book you know I can't say it's whatever
I'm reading at the moment it tends to
tends to be more than anyone so much
about this right like this Oracle
fiction so why should I throw fiction
into the mix to be treated I don't know
that's true that's a good answer very
good answer although you can be creative
with history just as I was asking you to
imagine and identify with the accusers
that's creative you're putting yourself
into the past yes the books that you've
written which one do you like the best
unanswerable you have a doctorate in
American history said how did you get
into the field of writing oh that's a
good question while I was in graduate
school I was doing some editing and that
got me into publishing my doctorate is
actually about the history of publishing
I've always been interested in the place
where create creativity and money cross
and that's publishing and so that's
so again thank you very much mark
Aronson is the publisher of cricket
books for children for more information
about his latest book witch hunt visit
Simon Says kids.com